[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: Data
centers use about 1%
of electricity in the world.
So today, let's explore how
data centers are powered,
especially in a
world confronting
the threat of climate change.
In September 2020,
Google CEO Sundar Pichai
unveiled that
Google would become
one of the first
companies to operate
carbon-free 24 hours a day, 7
days a week, 365 days a year
by 2030.
Carbon-free means
running data centers
on clean electricity that does
not come from fossil fuels.
But how does a global
technology company
with a constant
need for electricity
achieve the ability to slash
all of its carbon emissions
within a decade?
Well, that's a big question.
And to answer it, we
have to go back in time.
In 2006, Google installed
over 9,000 solar panels
in its Mountain View,
California buildings,
and learned how to optimize
our efficiency with tricks
like finding optimal
locations and washing them.
But six years
later, it was still
a unique and custom process
to buy renewable energy.
Traditional power companies
didn't have the experience
with the volume of wind and
solar that Google was seeking.
But fast-forward to
today, and Google
has become the largest corporate
purchaser of clean energy.
And utility companies now
have an idea of what's needed,
making it an industry standard.
Just like computer chips,
higher production volumes
create lower costs.
As clean energy has
gone mainstream,
the cost has declined.
And wind and solar are now
cheaper than any other resource
in many areas of the world.
Adding clean energy to grids is
only one part of the strategy.
Data centers also need to
be designed efficiently.
Historically, it took a
massive amount of cooling.
A data center
technician in the 1980s
would be wearing a
very thick sweater,
since temperatures inside were
around 58 degrees all the time.
Today, a T-shirt suffices.
A lot of effort has been placed
on designing better cooling
systems and isolating the hot
aisles from the cold aisles.
In fact, in 2018, a
data center engineer
created an ML algorithm
that exponentially improved
cooling loads by at least 30%.
This AI-powered efficiency
recommendation system
ingested all the
cooling system data
we had on power,
temperature, and pump speeds
and fed it to
neural networks that
learned how to operate the
mechanical systems more
efficiently.
Teams of engineers
also worked on how
to make the servers more
efficient to squeeze
more computation
out of each machine.
In the past, an idle
server could use just
as much energy as one that is
processing at max capacity.
One way to improve this capacity
was to virtualize machines.
That means you take a physical
device such as a server
and run multiple instances
of an operating system.
It's almost like having 10, 20,
or even 50 different computing
loads running on
one physical device,
keeping utilization high
and energy emissions low.
Between 2010 and 2018,
overall computing efficiency
grew by 550% in data centers.
And in 2019, Google reported
that its data centers delivered
over seven times as
much computing power
with the same amount
of electrical energy.
Google began to buy
enough solar and wind
energy to match its total
electricity use worldwide
since 2017, but there were
still more work to do.
For example, there
were still data centers
that could only use solar
energy during the day,
but at night were using
carbon-intensive energy
from the grid.
So the energy teams
at Google started
thinking about our mission in
a completely different way.
How could we match every
bit by search, payment,
and translation, to a
zero-carbon electron?
Googler Anna
Radovanovich understood
that there was a way
to use data to tell
when power was clean or
dirty at any given time.
Since Google logs data on
every single compute workload,
we could analyze
which tasks did not
need to happen immediately,
such as the training of machine
learning models.
These tasks could be safely
scheduled at a later time
and powered with clean energy
without affecting performance.
This is called demand
response, which
is not a new concept for big
energy consumers like grocery
stores, offices, or factories
who reduce their energy demand
at certain times of the day.
Even though this concept
has been around a long time,
Google is going about it
in a pretty unique way.
And carbon-aware
computing has made
a huge shift in the industry.
Although complicated,
it's key to decarbonizing
the digital economy.
By mid 2020, all the
elements came together--
incredibly cheap renewable
energy, radical improvements
in efficiency, higher-density
batteries, green hydrogen,
and novel types of
greener nuclear plants.
For the first time, Google
was able to put a firm
date on our 24/7 carbon goal.
This is so important to
us, as the next decade
is vital to limit
climate change and make
a huge shift in our relationship
with natural resources.
If you want to learn more,
check out the links below,
and stay tuned for more on
discovering data centers.